yes hi everybody this is Nick Gillespie
with reason and I'm joined by my uh
reason colleague Zach weismuller and
we're going to have a live stream
conversation with Michael schellenberger
the best-selling author of Apocalypse
never Michael thanks for joining us
great to be with you guys
um and I just want to say at the outset
we're going to be talking about the
environment uh and natural uh kind of
natural disasters and things like that
we won't be talking about uh your views
on mental health and things like that
just so if anybody was coming here to
because we you did a great uh interview
with Zach about your book San Francisco
and related issues so people can uh go
to that if they want to talk about that
right now we are talking about the
winter you know winter is coming in
Europe and it looks like it's going to
be a real [ __ ] show Zach do you want to
run a clip of Michael talking to
Congress earlier this year and then
we're going to uh we're gonna kick off
from there
here to the expansion of natural gas is
the war on natural gas President Biden
is Waging War on natural gas by refusing
to allow expanded gas production on
federal lands and offshore his
appointees at ferc are blocking the
expansion of natural gas pipelines as
well as LNG export terminals the result
is that we do not have enough oil and
gas production for ourselves and to
provide for our allies in Europe we've
been in this energy crisis for a year
now I was writing about the impacts in
Europe a year ago we should have been
acting then to be expanding gas
production to save our allies in Europe
who are going to have rationing and
Industrial collapse this winter
uh Michael can you explain what do you
mean when you talk about a war on gas
what what what comprises the war on gasp
well there's so much to it actually it's
it's pretty amazing so there's at the
ground level there's been a very
successful effort to block pipelines so
you may know that there's a pipeline
that Senator manchin has been trying to
get completed called The Mountain Valley
pipeline from West Virginia
there's pipelines that should be going
from The Gap oil and gas fields of
Pennsylvania to the east coast
particularly to Boston Boston has to
import natural gas by ship which is much
more expensive it's called liquefied
natural gas and they end up burning oil
during the winters last several Winters
they burn oil for electricity which is
very dirty and inefficient
so what what you want from an economic
and environmental point of view is you
want to have natural gas continue to
replace coal and that means you need a
lot of pipelines around the country the
other thing that you need is you need
more liquefied natural gas terminals
that basically cool the gas
to like I said negative couple hundred
degrees Centigrade they're pretty
amazing machines they then convert the
gas into liquids then they're shipped to
Asia and Europe huge market for that and
it will continue to Boom it's great for
Americans great for American jobs
there's some concerns that you don't
want to do so much of that that it
increases natural gas prices at home but
there's I think ways around that
particularly that's the role of having
abundant pipelines and gas
and then we've seen at the political
level Biden has approved fewer oil and
gas leases for public lands and offshore
than any president since President
Truman it's not even really an accurate
comparison because there just wasn't
that many oil and gases leases being
given out back then but basically Biden
has just you know just not given out
leases
and then there's in the financial sector
the so-called ESG movement which stands
for environment social and governance
they have definitely reduced private
sector investment in oil and gas
I will say whenever I point these things
out people point out that also the oil
and gas industry
is not making some of the increases of
production that it could be making
I agree with that although I will say
that I think that if you when you talk
to folks in that sector they're kind of
like we don't have any investment
certainty because we've got a government
that says it wants to shut us down and
so these private sector decisions are
being made with an eye because the
public sector the government
determine so much of how much oil and
gas production there will be and are we
going to shift all of our production for
energy to China in the form of
Renewables and electric cars so the war
on natural gas I would say if I had to
simplified I'd say it's happening the
Grassroots level at the governmental
Federal level and at the private sector
level before um I bring Zach in could
you talk a little bit about the ESG
component of this you know part of it so
part of it is that producers might not
be doing as much as they can because
they're not sure the regulatory uh
framework I think that kind of speaks
for itself but
um why would companies not you know why
would companies that can produce a lot
of natural gas not do it some you know
like where is where is the shareholder
pushback coming from and is that really
a problem if you know the people who own
a company say you know what we don't
want to produce as much of this stuff
anymore
yeah I mean it's very surprising to me I
mean I was
um you know I was at the time I mean the
the advocacy
to basically divest from fossil fuels
which is not just coal but also natural
gas and oil I remember at the time being
like well that's obviously not going to
work because if if you know if Harvard
pulls all of its billions out of natural
gas and oil companies
somebody else will rush in that's just
how markets work
but it actually has been so effective
and so successful they've managed to get
Pension funds and big endowments and
ordinary investors to
basically convincing them that the
future was in Renewables not in oil and
gas
that it did have an impact and to give
you one anecdote there was a oil and gas
uh producer in the United States called
EOG that announced it was going to
expand production and it's it's share
its stock price was actually punished by
investors who didn't want to see more
investment so again it's a little hard
to disentangle because I think there's
also been the the oil and gas industry
in the United States lost a lot of money
between 2010 and 2020
U.S consumers benefited at about a
hundred billion dollars a year in lower
energy prices
both gas and oil but the oil and gas
guys there's a lot of bankruptcies a lot
of failures they just didn't make very
much money in some ways it was a net
wealth transfer from the capitalist
class to Consumers which
as someone that's concerned about the
public interest it's actually kind of a
beautiful thing it's also thanks to that
that we reduce carbon emissions
but I think that's fair to say the oil
and gas guys want to make more money now
and they're happy to have a tighter
Supply
but it's it's a complex picture because
also they want the oil and gas leases
they're you know particularly in Alaska
but offshore the oil and gas companies
want those leases
one of the claims it's made is that
they're not using the leases they have
that it's it's not quite like that it's
more like they don't know which of the
areas that they've been given the oil
and the land and offshore are going to
actually be productive in terms of
investment so you want more areas
because they may not all be productive
or they might not produce enough to make
the investment worth it
so I yeah I mean I think it's kind of
amazing I I can't think of another
example of it where really you have a
kind of superior product in terms of
price which is oil and gas over say
electric vehicles or Renewables
and it being really punished in the
marketplace but that indeed is what's
occurred there's also been you know
efforts to change the boards of
directors of the big oil and gas
companies to some extent that's occurred
they have had a bunch of people on the
boards who are saying we need to move
away from oil and gas to Renewables in
fact I think the new CEO of shell in
particular is uh comes from the
Renewables division
so yeah I mean it's kind of an amazing
story that that really non-market forces
have had such a strong Market impact
Zach what do you uh what do you think
you know a lot of your work
um go it kind of touches on the way that
some of these changes end up either
being I don't know just purely ambition
or cosmetic and then we and you know
there's this effort to go towards some
cleaner energy source but then we end up
more reliant on some energy source that
we don't want to be and you had this
recent sub stack post about OPEC and how
you know now we're in the situation
where Biden wanted to put downward
pressure on gas prices so we we drained
the Strategic reserves
um and there was an opportunity to do
that uh more cheaply but now we're back
in a more expensive deal with OPEC could
you just lay that out a little bit
yeah and let me address the first thing
I think you're alluding to which is that
people that are listening that might
think
well we do need to move away from fossil
fuels because of climate change that is
my view long term certainly but to give
you a sense of it you know the
replacement of coal with natural gas in
the United States was the main reason
that we reduced our carbon emissions 22
between 2005 and 2020.
natural gas is also just cleaner in
terms of normal air pollution than coal
so I mean basically everybody's
intuitive since that natural gas is
better than coal is correct
and that's true for the Landscapes and
the water and the mining and all the
rest the other issue is that
um you know this oil and gas security
that we have in the United States it's
really precious it's game changing it
means that we're the largest oil and gas
producer in the world
this was a hard one security I mean it
really was from the last OPEC crisis in
the the last OPEC embargoes in the early
70s that there was this bipartisan
effort to expand technological
innovation to create the fracking
Revolution which is really a one of the
most important Innovations in
frankly world history you know it sounds
exaggerated but fracking really allowed
the United States to re-industrialize
bring fertilizer heavy manufacturing
back to the United States
so anyway oil and gas is very very
important from an economic and
environmental and National Security
point of view
now on this issue of OPEC
sorry I laugh I it's you know there's
what's going on in the world is actually
quite tragic and poor countries are
going to suffer the most and people are
going to die you know I mean bluntly
from lack of fertilizer from cold and
from pollution so it's not a funny
laughing matter but the behavior of the
body Administration
it's so shocking it's such a you know
what do they call what do the kids call
it such a clown car show
you know I mean they basically here we
had in 2020 we had the bottle fell out
of oil prices we had you know because of
covid oil prices declined to around 24 a
barrel Trump said well let's buy that
oil and reef and use it to top off the
Strategic petroleum Reserve Democrats
killed it led by Chuck Schumer who said
we didn't want to bail out of the oil
industry of Big Oil
well now we learn from some pretty good
reporting by CNN I'll give them credit
on this one
that the body administrations had been
secretly offering OPEC plus and by the
way the plus an OPEC plus refers to
Russia so offering uh OPEC plus
um basically 80 a barrel to refill the
Strategic petroleum Reserve in exchange
for OPEC not cutting production
I mean that's kind of shocking and then
and then of course OPEC plus passed on
it they said no we don't want to do that
the Biden Administration
I just think this is a case where
ideology can make you stupid where the
by Administration what they could have
done is just said hey you know Market
forces OPEC is going to do what OPEC is
going to do we don't control OPEC you
know we do control how much oil and gas
we produce domestically because we're
not part of OPEC
but instead they basically got
themselves in a situation where Biden
went to Saudi Arabia as you may remember
in July they fist bumped the Crown
Prince they've they said they were going
to lift sanctions on Venezuela they
reannounced that yesterday the Wall
Street Journal reported it today then
they came out to later today and they
said no we're not going to lift
sanctions on Venezuela now you've got
the head of the National Economic
Council Brian deese saying we're open to
any kind of policy options I mean I just
joke that he's going to go into Reddit
and start looking for ideas because
they're so intellectually bankrupt at
the White House
um it's hard not to take a little bit of
pleasure in the in just the total mess
that is occurring but it is serious
business in the sense that energy
shortages are gonna Crush I mean they're
just having a devastating impact on
Europe and not just this winter it's
going to be many Winters they're losing
aluminum glass steel manufacturing it's
very sad and dangerous
you you realize that you can't print
energy you can print money so they're
headed for a fiscal crisis that's driven
by the lack of energy what could they
because we talked about we just you just
talked a lot about what the Biden
Administration has done to contribute to
this but what could and should have
European countries done differently to
make themselves less reliant on Russian
gas so that when this disasters you know
Invasion happened they weren't stuck in
the situation they are now
yeah well so one data point is that
Europe produced more natural gas 15
years ago than Russia exports or then
Russia exported before its invasion of
Ukraine that's shocking they they Europe
allowed its natural gas production to
decline Europe has shales it has this
rock formation called Shale you know
about a mile Underground
they could have started fracking for it
they should have they actually started
mapping it out if you look like 10 10 15
years ago
the British and French and polish and
various governments were kind of looking
at it
and and intriguingly you have two
sources they may be the same source of
intelligence but the former Secretary
General of NATO and former Secretary of
State Hillary Clinton both said that
that Russia was funding anti-fracking
advocacy in Europe
a French Professor claimed the same
thing there's some rumors that they were
also finding anti-nuclear advocacy we
knew that the energy director the energy
Minister of Belgium her business partner
worked for gas prom which is the Russian
Gas Company
so yeah I mean Europe I think look the
big picture here is that Nations need
energy security if you don't have
domestic oil and gas production then you
need to either bring coal or nuclear
there's an environmentalist I prefer
them to build nuclear that's what
basically France did
not just after World War II but after
the early 70s OPEC shocks they just
scaled up nuclear it reached 80 percent
of total electricity at one point France
under pressure from Germany and under
its own kind of
internal self-loathing I call it
battered wife syndrome for the nuclear
industry they France decided that they
were going to shut down nuclear from 75
to 50 percent which meant increasing gas
consumption it's just bonkers
so yeah I mean um
what we should do now is that we should
help the Europeans to Frack their shales
and we should expand nuclear power right
now they're just going to burn a lot
more coal and tragically another tragedy
they're going to burn a lot of wood in
fact the demand for wood fuel has gone
up so much you guys that they've
actually capped the price of wood fuel I
mean it's uh this is in Europe I mean
this is you know it's we're not talking
about Albania this we're talking about
you know the thick of Western Europe
Central yeah
uh what explains uh well I guess first
off could you talk a little bit about
fracking and the type of energy that we
get out of that
um and why that is a categorically
different type of of fuel than burning
coal or oil out of the ground
um because this is one of the things I
can remember a time from your your
writing as well as reasons Ron Bailey
and others where things like natural gas
and fracking was considered it was going
to be a bridge fuel that
environmentalists liked that it was
going to help us get from an era of very
dirty uh energy to cleaner energy but we
weren't quite there yet and fracking and
natural gas seem to be you know the it
was going to be the bridge Fuel and now
it's vilified everywhere can you just
give us a short history of of what is
good and bad about uh the type of energy
you're saying we need more of
yeah so I mean just you know natural gas
it's the cleanest fossil fuel it's the
only fossil fuel you can burn in your
home
it's the only fuel that you can burn
your home without requiring elaborate
filtration systems uh that we did burn
colon homes but you had to have these
special stoves so we just have this
experience with gas it's
um just obviously the superior fuel it
was always viewed as kind of a waste
byproduct of petroleum until we started
you know creating natural gas hookups in
the early part of the 20th century
first half of the 20th century
um you know normally we were getting
both oil and gas from these reservoirs
these underground reservoirs you just
drill a single vertical uh well into it
and then the gas just comes out we
always knew that there was gas trapped
in between in tight Sands or shale
shale's a kind of rock formation but
it's a you know it's a we all kind of
experience with it it's a kind of uh
soft
um so we knew that gas was trapped in
there long story short there's a huge
effort by the US government I actually
was one of the first people to write the
history of it with the oil and gas
industry to figure out how to get that
gas out of shales it's such a cool
effort it gets reduced to fracking which
has a sort of you know because the way
the word sounds it just sounds bad but
basically you're drilling these these
Wells into the Shale and then you're
running these horizontal Wells and then
they can just run three 360 degrees and
then they they shoot out like this Frac
fluid and then with like little bits of
sand and then it holds open the Shale
and the gas comes out it's really
remarkable and they use underground
mapping 3D mapping to be able to see
where the gas where what hasn't been
fracked yet and what they need to move
around and get the gas from
so that was a huge game changer and then
also offshore uh gas production was a
huge game changer basically became clear
that gas wasn't this
highly limited resource that there was
abundant natural gas and and of course
as you know because Iran and others you
know that we don't run out of fuels we
actually find a more Superior Fuel and
move to it that was the case with wood
to Coal there were some Regional
shortages with wood but coal was more
abundant had higher heat content
and was cheaper and then gas became
cheaper so gas actually became cheaper
than coal which was something that
nobody thought was going to happen
so this was always well predicted in the
70s my mentors who are Jesse ossable and
Cesar marchetti who I write about in
Apocalypse never they kind of they had
this vision of these energy transitions
from wood to Coal to oil to Natural Gas
to uranium back in the 70s and that was
sort of mainstream views and you see
some environmentalists like Carl Pope of
the Sierra Club Michael Bloomberg
um who all were very Pro gas but then
Bill McKibben and others they started
putting out this bogus stuff saying that
gas was worse than coal which you know
violates your intuitive sense because of
course it produces half the emissions
half the carbon emissions is coal and
they said well but there's the leaks of
the gas which is methane and that's true
there is a methane is a more potent
greenhouse gas but it also is much
shorter lived and so it ends up
breaking down in the atmosphere before
carbon dioxide does so so it doesn't
really make sense it's still better
bottom line so yeah I mean I think that
um what can I say there was mass
formation psychosis around fracking
um similar to the the mass formation
psychosis around nuclear that's the term
term of advice we used to say moral
panics but right and people would say
for getting more scientific these days
right we have more complicated terms
yeah um is there uh you know one of one
of the fears about fracking is you know
that it destabilizes local you know
geology and it causes earthquakes it you
know is any of that accurate or is that
something we don't know enough about
because fracking has been around for
decades but not at the scale that we've
been doing it right right and the
fracking that we were doing that we're
doing now is much more into these shales
it's more horizontal so you're actually
creating more destabilization yeah I
mean there it does in some places create
small earthquakes
um they're really small I mean this is
not you know I mean yeah there can be
impact on houses it's something you have
to guard against there's ways to prevent
it and in some places you may not be
able to Frack
um but there's just so much Shale in the
United States and around the world that
you can there's definitely places you
can do it without having those small
Tremors impacting homes
and it's also by the way not a just a
consequence of fracking for gas the
older forms of gas most famously in the
grown again region of the Netherlands
they have a huge amount of gas but it's
be is they're taking so much gas out
that you're getting the sedimentation of
the um you're getting a kind of um
settling of the ground and so then the
houses are kind of falling apart and
you're getting these earthquakes but
it's a huge source of controversy
because Netherlands could be
significantly ramping up its gas
production but it won't
I guess the bottom line Nick I would say
is that there are obviously
environmental impacts of natural gas
production but they are seriously
outweighed by the impacts of coal in
terms of the impact on landscapes but
also water use and polluted water and
then even more just because it's an
energy density issue even more
outweighed by the impacts of of wood I
mean it's you may have seen the New York
Times article about the logging of of
birch in in trees in Romania and the use
of turning these I don't know if they
were ancient forests but certainly a
very old growth forest into firewood I
mean it's it's really one of the one of
the tragedies so anything I mean gas is
just a greatly Superior to that and
obviously then you have nuclear which is
the king of power but we're going to get
to nuclear in a second could you also
you you had mentioned in passing that
you know it this is not just a question
of people being cold in their houses
which you know in Europe which is bad
enough uh can you explain the knock on
effects of if if Europe if industrial
Europe Central Europe middle Europe
Western Europe southern Europe uh
doesn't have enough energy
um it's you know people are going to
freeze and some people will die from
that but it's also going to have these
other effects on what they make and how
they do it can you explain that a little
bit
yeah absolutely and thanks for asking
that because of course there's been a
number of government officials in Europe
um when they're trying to you know look
on the bright side they say things like
we have enough gas to get through the
winter what they're actually saying is
that we have enough natural gas to keep
our people warm through the winter they
are definitely not saying that they have
enough natural gas to keep electricity
or Energy prices low nor enough natural
gas to be able to provide for their
industrial purposes
so there are some Industries which can
switch from natural gas to petroleum or
coal but there's other Industries where
the natural gas is itself a feedstock
the most famous of course is fertilizer
which is uh nh4
nitrogen combined with hydrogen
or is it nh2 I guess I get my chemistry
mixed up but basically natural gas of
course is CH4 so you're taking the
carbon atom off and you're adding the
nitrogen atom that's how you get
fertilizer
there's other ones like aluminum
factories they have to be constantly
running to keep that molten glass from
clogging up the pipes there is steel
manufacturing which depends on cheap and
abundant energy
so and and that's sort of the main event
I mean there's always been recognition
there's been a debate and I don't know
that you I think there's a way in which
some may be impossible to ever calculate
but there's been a debate among
economists about
how how important is manufacturing to
the economy I think it's fair to say
that everybody agrees it's more it's
more important than other sectors at
this point there's some people that kind
of go you know retail manufacturing
manufacturing provides so much value in
such high paying jobs has many more
knock-on effects than say opening a
Walgreens or a drugstore
um also which are impacted by high
energy prices so it's really the
potential loss of this heavy
manufacturing and particularly in
Germany not only but certainly in
Germany
Spain and Portugal you know it's just in
Portugal and they get
you know uh like 50 billion dollars over
the next five or ten years from the EU
just transferred to them Portugal's you
know it's a tourist economy right you
know it's not doesn't have the heavy
industry so Portugal I found people very
relaxed about this energy crisis but I
was kind of like look your whole economy
depends on the industrial Powerhouse of
Germany if you lose that Portugal will
be affected not just from the tourists
that don't come but just even in the net
transfers the whole lifeblood of the
European Union the lifeblood of the
European economy is in its energy
intensive heavy Industries all of that
is in Jeopardy right now and in serious
Jeopardy how does the rupturing of the
Nordstrom pipelines affect that
situation because uh one of your more
controversial sub stacks and there's a
lot of controversial ones uh highlighted
this tweet from a former polish defense
minister where he seemed to be thanking
the U.S uh alleged you know implying
that they were responsible for what
happened there there why did you
highlight that and what did you think
about the plausibility of the claim and
then just more broadly what's the
Practical effect of what happened there
all right well you you pointed out it's
very controversial so I want to be very
careful of the way I talk about it I
reported that I've reported a couple
things basically the first is that the
the former defense minister of Poland
not some random dude on the internet
credited the United States with blowing
up Nordstrom one and two Pipelines
I have not speculated about who did it
however I've also noted and just
observed who might have an interest in
taking out the pipeline and the things
that people have said about the pipeline
so it's worth pointing out that Biden
when he was asked about the pipeline
back in February a reporter said
you know we're asked about the pipeline
he said if Russia invades Ukraine we're
going to take out the Nordstrom
Pipelines
and the person was like well how could
you do that you don't own the pipelines
they're not yours and he said trust me
we'll take them out something like that
so I mean you kind of come on you gotta
report that at least
and you have to report on what the
Polish Former Defense secretary said
and then if you actually read the media
coverage of course there's this you know
very quick to say well of course the
United States would never have done this
so I mean the United States would never
do something like this and of course
Russia is evil and so if something bad
happened then of course Russia did it
but if you actually read what the
analysts say and I'm an analyst too
it's hard to figure out how this was in
Russia's interests
you can easily see how it would be
something that the United States might
want to see happen but Russia has been
able to turn on and off supply of that
gas pipeline
it didn't need to blow it up now you can
make these different Arguments for it we
can get into it more in some ways it
doesn't really matter but I will point
out that afterwards Russia has been just
totally consistent that it did not blow
up its own Pipeline and the United
States said the same thing but then you
also had Anthony blinken the Secretary
of State say well this is a great
opportunity for Europe to move to
Renewables
so I just found some of those behaviors
a little suspicious
um but in terms of the Strategic
importance I mean first of all that was
a huge that's I mean as these were big
pipelines to bring in lots of natural
gas into Europe they were very important
yes there is another pipeline that goes
for turkey called turkey stream and
there's pipelines that go through
Ukraine they don't provide nearly as
much gas so for Russia it was certainly
a lot of gas
I mean there is a part of me that
actually is glad that the pipeline is no
longer there I'm not sure I agree with
the idea that it should be blown up but
I think there is something to it which
is to say one thing you worry about is
that you start to get governments in
Europe that basically say uh we want to
end support for the war in Ukraine in
exchange for restarting gas from Russia
I worry about that because I do think it
strengthens Putin I think he is a bad
actor and he should be contained
in the old-fashioned Cold War view of
containment I haven't written about
Ukraine and so I don't really have a
view of whether that's good or bad to
support that effort but I don't love the
idea of the European Union being divided
on whether or not to restart gas flows
from Russia
is it is it safe to say that you know
what you strip out the politics and
whatnot but what this kind of
illustrates is that if Europe is so
heavily reliant on one provider of
energy
you put yourself in a you know you're
you're kind of putting your own hat on
The Chopping Block right because if that
if something goes wrong like let's say
you know it's not that the Nordstrom
gets blown up or that Russia is revealed
as a bad actor but you know there's a
Revolution in Russia and the energy
stops flowing yeah you know that then
Europe is kind of screwed
absolutely I mean that's the big lesson
Nick it's it's as usual the big lessons
are the simplest and the most obvious
but the ones that we tend to run past
but which is that energy security
is Paramount for every nation
particularly big Nations that other
smaller Nations rely on like Germany or
like the United States and this is why
it would be absolute Madness for the
United States to become dependent on
China for Renewables particularly solar
wind and electric vehicles they have
I don't say a monopoly but they have
huge dominance over the materials mind
them refining and the materials
production as well as the actual
production of solar panels so it would
be crazy to sacrifice that Democrats
kind of wave their hands on this issue
when I raise it with them they kind of
go well we'll reassure those Industries
let's reassure the industries first
before becoming dependent on them I have
other reasons to think that'll never
happen because of the high cost of
Renewables and the big environmental
impacts but nonetheless I think the
obvious lesson is that you wouldn't want
them to go trade our hard one energy
security for dependence on China
well yeah Zach can we run that clip of
the uh of the Trump uh ad and let's use
that as a kind of palette cleanser to to
talk more about this question of energy
security or Independence or dominance
as the highest energy cost in its
history
and we are no longer energy independent
or energy dominant which we were just
too short years ago
we are a nation that is begging
Venezuela and Saudi Arabia for a while
so that's a clip from a kind of you know
campaign ad that Trump uh released a
couple days after the raid on Mar-A-Lago
on one of his social media Network sites
um you know uh Michael what what does he
get right and wrong in kind of talking
about energy in those terms
I mean I by the way I never voted for
the guy
um I voted for Hillary and Biden just to
get that out there so you are part of
the problem because you know there was
there was a Libertarian in both of those
races who would have we wouldn't be
having these problems yeah we would be
having a wide range of other problems
but certainly not those trying to make
up for it now Nick I'm trying to make up
for my reporting right um I mean look
Trump looks great right now on energy I
mean there's just you can't I just
I just don't think there's any other way
to read it I mean his very direct and
blunt warnings at the United Nations
that Germany was becoming overly
dependent on Russia
the way a video of that we have a video
of him bluntly warning the Germans
across the table who are laughing during
that UN speech they're like come on why
does you know this guy is full of [ __ ]
right in just that most patronizing way
I love Germans by the way I mean I have
huge respect for the Germans but there
is that side of them the pomposity and
the smugness that comes across very
strongly that was also by the way of
course the moment that Trump is being
accused by everybody as being a Russian
agent like a you know like a Manchurian
Candidate For Putin and here he is
warning Europe against it by the way as
a side note I went and looked back at
the mainstream news media coverage of
trump I suspected at that time I suspect
it would be bad
it was unbelievable they were actually
fact-checked Trump and they claimed that
he was not telling the truth about
Europe's dependence and of course Trump
because he's Trump he made some
exaggerations he said things like you
know
40 of its energy as if it's a 40 of its
gas I mean stuff but it was real
nitpicky stuff the broad direction that
Trump was going and was spot on
and absolutely I mean like energy I
think this is uh it's hard for people
people if you don't understand energy
you can get a lot of things wrong in
terms of economics and also in foreign
policy but what we saw is that Europe
became overly dependent on Russia for
for energy and it was and therefore
there wasn't a deterrent on Russia being
able to invade Ukraine now Russia might
have invaded Ukraine no matter how
dependent Europe was on Russian energy
but it meant that that Europe wasn't
able to harm Russia economically in the
ways that it could have had it been less
dependent on Russia for energy now we
see Biden going to Saudi Arabia I mean
but you have to remember Biden in I
believe 2019 certainly in the
presidential the recent presidential
election he said that Saudi Arabia
should be a pariah State given that we
the overwhelming evidence that the the
crown Saudi Crown Prince was involved in
the killing of uh the journalist at
Washington Post khashoggi and and then
you kind of and then there's a on
there's a civil suit against the Crown
Prince of Saudi Arabia debate over
whether he should be whether he has
sovereign immunity or whether he should
be tried the United States the Biden
Administration has now intervened in
that lawsuit and said that he should
basically
um they've it's complex but basically
taking the side that he should not be uh
tried here in the United States for
these things so you can already see in
the case of Saudi Arabia Venezuela the
United States having to kind of
you know change its position rather than
just do the obvious thing which is to
produce more oil domestically
is energy Independence really possible
in the you know the world that we live
in where resources are spread all over
the globe it's kind of like you got to
pick you're always going to be dependent
on some other country for some material
or some input that goes into the kind of
energy you're producing I mean with
nuclear I was reading that like 40 of
some sort of uranium enrichment
technology is in Russia uh so it's like
you go solar with and you're relying on
rare Earths out of China or you go
nuclear and you have this new dependency
on some sort of Russian technology
um and or wherever the minerals uh
happen to be
um and then also just having the
interdependence you know the theory
generally has been that it's it's good
to have some level of interdependence
because that forces you know coming to
diplomatic Solutions rather than trying
to build some sort of self-sustain
training autography that creates you
know higher likelihood of War
yeah
yeah I mean I use the word energy
security because I think that's the
right thing to be looking at not energy
Independence Robert Bryce makes a very
similar point and rightly so that some
amount of interdependence is good and we
think trade is good and we think trade
is good for Nations and it's good for
you know it prevents Wars you know it is
an incentive against Wars you know could
be you can also obviously you know
reduce the deterrent for Invasion like
we saw in Europe but generally no I
agree I think some amount of
interdependence is good I also think a
lot of security is good now the
interesting thing about the United
States is because of our geography
covering such a vast landscape and a
particular landscape we could be very
very independent much more independent
than almost anybody else
you know we have a lot of uranium in the
United States it's we certainly could do
more uranium uh refining making more of
our own fuels we have tons of oil and
gas we have tons of coal hopefully
moving away from it but certainly we
could manufacture solar panels
um uranium fuel rods I think we are
unusual in that sense you know like
France doesn't have uh benzo oil and gas
although it does have shales
but yeah you want to see more security
and that is why in many ways nuclear is
the
the Crown Jewel of the energy system
because it provides the highest level of
security you know if you have your
nuclear power plants you can stockpile
just gigantic quantities of fuel Without
Really any trouble
so I think that security is the right
way to look at it I would say if you if
you if you love America and you think
that we have a really great uh system of
democracy and that we are a more
benevolent than malevolent influence on
the world
then I think what we should be doing is
expanding nuclear power at home
and then and then so that we can export
more natural gas abroad both to help our
allies in Europe and Asia but also as a
way to support liberal democracies
around the world you know exporting
natural gas is a great way to to gain
relationships with the Nations it's
notable that's what Putin did he
replaced a lot of the gas production at
home with nuclear power so I think
that's the right direction of travel to
go in
let's um you know this brings up a
question for me of you know so enter
going into energy security is the idea
that we would you know have more control
over Source you know sources of fuel and
energy at home we you know if we're
Europe you would have you know some
production capacity you know in your
country whether it's nuclear or you're
talking about the Netherlands with the
uh fracking and things like that and
you're going to be picking up stuff from
other places as well
um but then there's this sense of
urgency and this you know in prepping
for this I was talking to Zach I you
know just over the past couple of weeks
I've been talking to a lot of younger
people that you know they tend to be
Millennials and gen Z but you know let's
say under 40. and one of the things that
they talk about is like you know Michael
like you might be saying okay well we
can use natural gas for a while blah
blah blah and they're pretty adamant
that no there is not time for that like
we need to decarbonize the you know we
need to decarbonize the economy now and
if not by now than by 2050 at the latest
Zach do you want to throw up that chart
and you want to explain this a little
bit uh Zach where this comes from but
this kind of speaks to that sense of
urgency yeah so the you know the ipcc
report always talks about you know are
are we gonna warm by 1.5 degrees Celsius
uh by 2100 or 2 degrees Celsius by then
um and then the world economic Forum
kind of put together this infographic
that lays out the difference between
that that half degree difference which I
guess is dependent on how aggressively
we decarbonize in the next 30 Years and
so yeah you can see you know it shows
you know doubling of uh hold on it's
hard for me to see on a little screen
here but
um
uh I hear
I guess the the question is you know
um
How concerned should we be
about
um
that half degree difference and uh How
likely is it that
um we're gonna you know achieve that
yeah I mean so so let's just let's talk
about some basic things that everybody
agrees on
um
more warming is worse than less warming
you know where we built our civilization
in a particular temperature band our
cities our Farms our natural areas
and so we all else being equal we don't
want to see temperatures rise that much
of course not all else is equal and that
all of our security and prosperity is a
result of cheap energy and in general
and in particular because of fossil
fuels
um I think we also know that the biggest
cause of emissions reductions in the
United States which had the largest
emissions reductions in world history
were mostly due to the switch from coal
to Natural Gas
so I don't have a lot of patience for
people that tell me that they're they
have an urgent view of climate change
but then are opposed to natural gas if
you want to urgently reduce carbon
emissions you need to use more natural
gas and you can just look at what's
happening now we're going to burn more
coal this year than any other period in
history
even though we don't need to be because
of the war on natural gas so if more
natural gas lowers emissions right now
in the short term
you guys know I'm a huge advocate of
nuclear power and I think ultimately
where we're going
I want to build nuclear plants as
quickly as I can but it takes a while
and it takes you know it's gonna the
first few ones are going to take 10
years we're going to get faster at it if
you build the same kind of reactors with
the same people Japanese at the end of
its last nuclear build was getting was
building a reactor in two years which is
like the blink of an eye for nuclear so
that's where you want to go but if you
want to reduce emissions right now you
use more gas and less coal and wood
that's kind of the bottom line and I'm
I'm not a huge fan of this it's just
false Precision to be able to say
here's the here's how these species are
impacted at these temperatures
you know there's already a lot of
uncertainty around what the temperature
change would be from an existing amount
of accumulated carbon dioxide emissions
it's called the climate sensitivity
but then there's huge uncertainties
about the impacts on natural landscapes
on on natural disasters on impacts but
it's more like direction of travel is
what matters you know you want to if
you're using coal you want to go to
natural gas if you're using natural gas
you want to go to nuclear you should not
shut down your nuclear plants if you're
going to add more nuclear then build
more reactors at the sites that you have
I'm a big adjacent possible type of
person so I'm always sort of like just
very practical at this point is there is
there a drop off I mean because this is
you know and and I'm you know sensitive
to this when I think you know going back
to you know the 90s really there has
been a persistent
you know message that is being sent that
the Earth is in Balance you know the
Earth is imperiled and that you know if
we go one degree too far it's kind of
like frying an egg where you you can't
bring it back that you know it's cooked
and that's it is that fundamental
framework which I think is embedded
deeply in the minds of younger people is
that just wrong and do how do we reach
people to suggest that this is not you
know it is not that one degree too far
and then everything ignites uh yeah
well and by the way
um so first of all yes that's wrong
that's
um you're that's the imposition of a
kind of both false Precision but also a
kind of apocalyptic tipping points
religiosity onto the natural world
that's not there
to give you a sense of it for Apocalypse
never I went and looked at these
scenarios that predicted the collapse of
Agriculture at four degrees Centigrade
and there's no there's no science to
that you know the fact of the matter is
that we can produce food at very high
temperatures around the world and the
main event remains whether you have
access to fertilizer irrigation and
tractors so sub-Saharan Africa will have
huge increases in food production at
high temperatures if it just uses modern
forms of farming rather than it's
currently
pre-modern forms of of farming you know
there's other tipping points there's
this kind of daisy chain scenario where
they kind of go the the the Gulf Stream
shuts down the Atlanta the Amazon lights
on fire and burns uncontrollably
methane's released it's this kind of um
there's not it's not science it's
science it's science storytelling or
science fiction but it's certainly not
anything that the ipcc uses for its
scenarios
it's um you know voslav smile who's one
of Bill Gates's big guys he's now a
best-selling author I believe he's
become quite famous but he wrote a
really good book on global catastrophes
looking at all the different forms of
global catastrophes including
super volcanoes and wars and pandemics
and asteroids
you know it actually made me a little
bit of an asteroid alarmist I must admit
I'm actually very much in favor of these
efforts to kind of knock asteroids off
of their trajectory
um but it was hard to find a apocalyptic
scenario on climate change because it's
just a kind of gradual increase of
temperatures that's what climate change
is it's the average increase it's an
increase of
of average temperatures over time so
yeah like you don't want it to get
really hot but it just really has to be
understood as an incremental uh impacts
rather than sort of tipping points or
apocalypse there's some claims that were
already seeing some of these effects and
I just want to play this clip of Biden
recently down in Florida where I am
where we were just hit by a category 4
hurricane
um and he made this comment reservoirs
out west or are down to almost zero
we're in a situation where the Colorado
River looks more like a stream there's a
lot going on
and I think the one thing this has
finally ended is a discussion about
whether or not there's climate change we
should do something about it but folks I
also want to uh Jill and I have had you
all in our prayers
what's your reaction to that
well climate change is real we don't
need them we can we have good
temperature data now we have both good
land base temperatures we also have good
ocean temperature data so clearly
temperatures are rising I think the
evidence is very strong but it's almost
entirely if not entirely caused by
humans we know carbon dioxide and other
greenhouse gases are heat trapping so
for me that no that's an issue what I
object to is the claim that hurricanes
are becoming more frequent and intense
there is no good evidence that that's
what's occurring to give you a sense of
it there have been 15 category four and
five hurricanes those the largest
hurricanes
over the last hundred years 10 of them
were before 1960 and five were since
1960. I pointed out that if you go look
at the full data set from going back to
the Early to 1900 or from the early or
from the 19th century there's no
increase in land falling hurricanes in
the United States of all kinds or major
hurricanes that goes actually a slight
downward Trend but but it's within the
realm of uncertainty but nonetheless
um and why do we look at landfall in
hurricanes because we those are much
more reliably measured in the period
before satellites so I wrote a piece
this week where I objected to the fact
that Financial Times showed Rising
hurricane frequency since the 19th
century they did that they created that
graph in violation of explicit warnings
by the National Oceanic and
administrative Administration that that
was not accurate that is not reliable
and that all of the increase that they
can detect is due to better detection
measures namely satellites which can
spot 100 basically of hurricanes whereas
in the 19th century you could rely on
probably get land falling most land
falling hurricanes but not all of them
and certainly not ocean-based ones
and in terms of fires we know that we
are not doomed to high intensity fires
in California because of climate change
you have to manage the forest through
mechanical clearing and prescribed Burns
to reduce the Woody buildup of fuels in
the forest that's not true and in terms
of droughts we've had huge droughts
forever in California we had two periods
of Mega droughts lasting over a century
I believe in the
ninth and
and 12th century or 11th century we had
huge mega droughts that lasted for like
more than a century in California so
it's not to say that climate change
isn't having an impacts it will
particularly we can see that there's
there's going to be impacts in terms of
temperature extremes heat waves and
precipitation but those are not the same
as natural disasters natural disasters
are strictly measured as deaths and
costs and on neither of those measures
uh in fact on both of those measures uh
the costs and the deaths are going down
which is why what are the what are
considered natural disasters the number
of what are considered natural disasters
actually declined from the year 2000
through 2021.
if the if you're in agreement though
that you know you said earlier that it's
better all else being equal if there's
less warming just because those changes
will be less dramatic and easier to cope
with therefore net you know leaning into
natural gas and eventually nuclear uh
more strongly makes sense the the thing
you hear often from Advocates of
Renewables as well look at the prices of
uh renewable technology over time
they've been consistently dropping I'm
going to share a graphic that gets
shared often
um that just you know shows the price of
vote uh solar panels and wind turbines
and battery power going down and down
and down and becoming more and more cost
effective
um why do you think that that's not a
winning argument
well it's true I mean the cost of of
producing solar panels wind turbines
electric cars electric vehicles has gone
down
the electricity from solar and wind has
uh the cost of it has gone down
but the sun doesn't always shine and the
wind doesn't always blow and the cost of
dealing with the inherent intermittency
or unreliability of solar and wind
makes electricity very expensive so we
saw the electricity in California is now
the most expensive electricity in the
continental United States it increased
Sevenfold between uh the year 2000
um sorry between 2010 and 2020 uh we've
seen the same thing in Australia you see
the same thing in Europe that adding a
lot of solar and wind the costs of
managing the unreliability outweigh the
savings of the electricity produced by
those Technologies
now the but there is another issue which
is just that there is an energy security
issue now you could say well we can
bring solar panel and wind production
back to the United States but that means
the solar panels and the wind turbines
are not going to be cheap anymore
they're going to be much more expensive
you have to remember that the solar
panels and the key ingredient
polysilicon in solar panels is
overwhelmingly made in xinjiang Province
same thing for lithium batteries for
electric cars
for me this is a fundamental moral issue
you cannot import products being made by
incarcerated weaker Muslims and
concentration camps full stop
that's effectively financing what the
state department calls a genocide I have
a bunch of people that claim that this
is not the case but but the bundestag
and the state department and BBC and New
York Times and people that actually are
big boosters of china made solar panels
and electric vehicles
um all agree that that is what's going
on people are being rounded up and put
in concentration camps and they're being
offered a chance to work in the solar
panel and Battery factories you bring
those firms back to the United States
and those products are not going to be
anywhere close as cheap
and then that doesn't then that doesn't
even deal with the um you know there's a
huge waste problem that nobody has dealt
with on solar panels and wind turbines
which according to review and Harvard
Business Review says would increase the
cost of electricity from solar by
four-fold whereas nuclear already
includes the cost of Waste Management in
its electricity production
do you um where where does the
um where does the hesitancy about
nuclear power come from and I realize
that's a large question but if we have
nuclear power
um and obviously it's been winding down
uh in a kind of profound way in the U.S
and also in Europe but where is the
hesitancy uh you know or or the you know
when you talk to people and again
especially younger people they talk a
lot about wind and solar uh and the
batteries that will buffer the
intermittency of you know of these
sources and nuclear just kind of
disappears Michael you know we're a bit
older than Zach so we remember you know
when nuclear was the promise and then
when nuclear became the nightmare with
Three Mile Island and Chernobyl and
Fukushima to a degree
um you know how do we get past that kind
of blind spot for nuclear power
particularly new forms of nuclear power
that are going to be smaller and less
kind of fear inducing
yeah I mean it is a huge question it's
hugely complex and super interesting and
I think maybe one of the most important
questions in the world which is why I
dedicate a lot of Apocalypse never to it
but also now I'm writing a second book
the war on nuclear why it hurts us all
that's going to come out next year I
think it's really interesting I mean
there's there's sort of financial
motives there's political motives and
then there's I would say spiritual or
psychological motivations against
nuclear on financial the problem with
nuclear is that they're a little bit
like hydroelectric dams that when you
build them
they pay themselves off after 30 years
and then they can run for 80 to 100
years or longer they're functionally
Immortal because you can just replace
the parts over time that means that
people that are trying to make money off
of producing electricity are deprived
that opportunity so you see rent seekers
in particular are threatened by nuclear
if you have nuclear you don't need
Renewables if you have nuclear you
really don't need anything else let me
look at France right so nuclear
threatens the financials of of what I
would I assume is it is it safe to say
that you know kind of natural or gas and
oil in interests were anti-nuclear
back in the day because they were like a
direct competitor and a better
competitor
oh for sure and I document the financing
of oil and gas investors and into
attacking nuclear for sure now that's
not it's not the whole sector I mean
there's certain parts of the sector that
were more aligned with Renewables those
are the guys that were attacking nuclear
particularly over the last 10 years when
gas was cheap and they had the alliance
with Renewables
I think the political motivations are
similar which is that you know if you're
trying to get support for a green green
New Deal
and you want to have all this money for
community non-profits and basically all
sorts of rent seeking and and and you're
trying to kind of control people's lives
through a super grid where you can
control when people use their
dishwashers and you can exercise the
sort of significant amount of social
control then I think you are against
nuclear
um it also deprives the the other kind
of it just you know
like if you have a nuclear-powered
economy with zero emissions then you
don't need to moralize about the need to
ride your bike or take mass transit or
whatever you can you can just 55 States
lives doesn't really matter right how it
is fascinating if I might just I'm sorry
Zach if I might just point out that uh
you know both in the students for a
Democratic Society Port Huron Statement
and Young Americans for Freedom the
right wing group The Sharon statement in
the early 60s they both literally took
for granted the idea that we would have
free ubiquitous non-polluting energy uh
that that would not be something we
would be dealing with and in many ways
they were you know they they took
different paths to kind of like what do
you do in a world where everything is
possible that that was kind of the
existential challenge not yeah you know
what do you do in a world of reduced
circumstances and possibilities for life
yeah and this sort of backlash to that
vision of cheap and abundant
um nearly unlimited energy and thus
basically every other resource the
backlash to it was identical to the
backlash by Robert Thomas Malthus the
British Economist in the late 18th
century who when that very same vision
was proposed by Godwin and konderset and
the other Enlightenment
uh utopians really people that thought
that technological progress would allow
for you know really an end to sickness
and death and human freedom and it was
very exciting and Thomas was like this
is terrible you know all this human
freedom and there have to be constraints
it came from a deeply kind of
I don't know anti-human I think is the
best word for it
um impulse a kind of like that's CR I
don't want to see humans with all this
potential and that got to I think the
spiritual issues which is that you know
it it that there there was sort of a
revulsion and a very deep psychological
and spiritual level to abundance and
that may seem strange because I think
the vast majority of people want
abundance but I think there is a very
powerful very intelligent uh very
intellectual group of people that are
revolted by Universal abundance and
Universal freedom and they want the
control they want to have the means to
control the society and to control other
people and to keep other people down
that's certainly certainly a big part of
the early environmentalist movement or
you know up through the mid 70s and this
is you know the Club for Growth is part
of this and Paul Ehrlich like there is a
revulsion saying no that's a pipe dream
but also even if it were true it is
distasteful morally or spiritually to
just have more than you need and we
should want less and less do you think
that's still at work because again going
back to the conversations and I realized
that you know this is a small sample and
whatnot the younger people that I talk
to I mean environmentalism you know kind
of green energy and the sh the need to
get away from carbon in all forms
um you know it's it's very deeply
heartfelt it's been pumped into them
since they were in the womb and it
doesn't seem to come from that sense of
revulsion at like abundance it's like no
this is the existential problem that my
generation is going to deal with that
the world is going to become unlivable
they don't seem to be that upset about
the idea that oh you know you'd be able
to keep your cell phone charged you know
it without uh Without End
I agree with you in fact it makes me
very optimistic because in some ways
that's the exact same vision I have
which is a vision of of radical
um abundance and radical decoupling to
use a bit of jargon of human welfare
from environmental destruction and I
think it's no surprise then that those
Zoomers and younger Millennials are are
much more open and enthusiastic about
nuclear what's missing is some
understanding of the physics of energy
and the fact that energy density is what
determines environmental impact
energy high energy densities reduce the
amount of material use the amount of
natural resource that's required for
producing energy and everything else in
the society so I mean I do I think this
is like a you know this is a brilliant
tool for decar for dematerialization
because you can you don't need a stereo
console system a television set you can
just use your iPhone but it requires a
lot of energy so no I agree with you
Nick I I think that's really positive
and I think that
I think once those folks understand more
of the technological problem the
inherent physical problems and Technical
and therefore technological and economic
problems with Renewables and the huge
benefits of nuclear I think that they
will end up embracing more of this
pro-human pro-abundance Vision exactly
we're at about an hour Zach do you want
to take us out what's on your mind too
yeah well I I've seen a lot of that
abundance or that enthusiasm for nuclear
among younger politically active people
and among Libertarians uh and I think
you're you know
um no small part of uh bolstering that
enthusiasm
um but uh the question I often get from
Libertarians about this is
um you know the economics of nuclear and
like is it actually viable you know as a
market technology we we all know like
the history of nuclear technology came
out of a massive government program Ram
the the Manhattan Project is what you
know split split the atom and everything
and it's always been very tied up with
the government
um there's a chart that nuclear critics
often put up here which is like the
level eyes this is the lizard levelized
cost of uh certain Energy Technologies
and you can see nuclear uh in the kind
of third from the bottom there is you
know not as good as gas or coal
um you know even uh you know solar
appears like solar farms and stuff
appear to out compete it
um so I mean how is that how much of
that is a relic do you think uh or you
know an outcome of the the kind of
extremely tight regulation around
nuclear how much of it is that nuclear
really would just need to be a pretty
much you know a government-run energy
program
um or is there you know hope for a
market-based type nuclear future
sure and let's just take on that chart
for a second here I mean I think what
they're saying the chart shows buying a
new solar panel the electricity from a
new solar panel uh is cheaper than the
electricity from a new nuclear plant of
course it's not cheaper than electricity
from an existing nuclear plant almost
nothing is cheaper than the electricity
from existing nuclear plant and you
might say well but you could say about
anything that's true you could although
the difference is that nuclear plants
last for so long solar panels are
replaced every 15 or 20 years whereas
these nuclear plants last for 80. and in
fact I'm a huge defender of existing
plants and think that the best way to
and the cheapest way to expand them is
by just adding reactors to existing
plant sites
in terms of the role the government
you know most of our Energy Technologies
come from the government Bell Labs under
U.S subsidies created the dominant form
of solar panel wind turbines were
heavily subsidized in Denmark and around
the world the Chinese government has
heavily subsidized these Technologies
natural gas turbines came out of Jet
Plane development including combined
cycle always received money from the US
government
uh nuclear is special in the sense that
it is a dual use technology and so
there's always going to be some amount
of government oversight
the economics are pretty straightforward
um and there's not really any debate
about it bigger plants produce cheaper
electricity because you don't need as
many workers to build operate or
regulate those plants
as you do
um uh um or you get more electricity you
don't need as you don't need a commonly
large number of people I hope that's
clear
um and then the other issue is just the
same workers building the same kind of
reactor over and over again is the only
way we know how to reduce the costs
so my view is America is a very
libertarian country I've actually come
to appreciate that a little bit more in
my old age
um and but mostly nuclear has kind of
state-owned Technology around the world
but the way the United States has always
done it and I think that the future of
nuclear is going to look a lot like the
past of nuclear that nothing has
occurred with the technology or the
physics or the tech or the economics to
change how it'll occur
the United States had two national
champions this is our our alternative to
state-owned Enterprises it was
Westinghouse and General Electric those
two technologies are still there
I would like to see the United States
government and this may be a
you know just too much interference for
Libertarians but nonetheless I think
it's sensible that the United States
government would make a commitment that
we want to expand nuclear to something
like 50 of our electricity up from 20 by
say 2050 and that you would have two
national champions
both of whom I think would have foreign
Partners like you might do the
Westinghouse with the French or the
Koreans and you might do the General
Electric and the Hitachi with the
Japanese
and you would create some incentives
nothing super onerous to encourage the
expansion of nuclear domestically I
think we can do it in a way that will
satisfy most reasonable Libertarians
that will create some competition
between designs and firms but also try
to capture those economies of scale that
are so essential to Bringing Down the
price of nuclear
uh Zach you've got a couple of comments
from our audience which is online at
YouTube and Facebook and Twitter
um Michael Let's uh do a rapid fire on
some of these uh questions Zach you want
to uh pose them yeah hold on I just lost
the track of it for a second
um
and while he's doing that uh Michael is
it is it a good sign that Germany has
walked back some of its anti-nuke uh you
know actions and that in California that
Gavin Newsom you know has extended the
life of Diablo Canyon uh you know a
controversial nuclear power plant there
California is 100 good news it's maybe
one of the happiest uh moments of my
life was helping to save that plant it
also was it's also somewhat bizarre but
like you're never sure how much of a
role you play because also there was in
fact we have a huge energy crisis we
didn't have enough electricity
but I think Germany and Belgium which
also is shutting down its nuclear plants
show that countries that are fanatically
anti-nuclear will still shut their
plants down in an energy crisis and that
local pro-nuclear advocacy definitely
plays a positive role the German
situation is so crazy Nick basically the
energy the economy and energy Minister a
guy named Robert hayback is a die-hard
green it's literally like one of his
life goals was to shut down Germany's
nuclear plants but then they're in this
huge energy crisis so he said well we're
going to keep
two of the three operating past January
but only on emergency need basis even as
they're of course massively expanding
coal production
and then Belgium did shut down a nuclear
plant late last month so
um
so it's I would just say you know the
the our local comrades in Germany need
to step up their campaign to pressure
payback he really needs to be fired I
mean it really needs to be a campaign to
fire the economy Minister he's so
grossly irresponsible he's hurting
Germany so Germany is touch and go at
this moment there's definitely other
countries that have recommitted to
nuclear in a big way Japan South Korea
and France and Britain all come to mind
but Germany and Belgium the kind of the
dark heart of the green movement of
Europe are still they're still they
haven't yet uh finally admitted the need
for nuclear no I'll also just point out
in passing that Belgium is also the
birthplace of the Smurfs uh so they have
a lot to answer for that explains a lot
actually do you have uh comments yeah
there's a comment down there at the
bottom says uh I heard the only way to
get nuke plants insured is with
government backing don't know if that's
true uh what what role you know does
government-backed Insurance have on the
reality of nuclear
yeah I mean it's true that the
government does
um ensure the insurers so the nuclear
plants do need to get private insurance
uh and then the government provides a a
limited liability
but when you look at it a lot of
Industries have limited liability so you
have it for big chemical plants you
obviously have doctors have limited
liability there's just a set of
industries that we provide limits on the
liability
because the you know there there's just
a risk of those costs of lawsuits
becoming so large that they make it
uneconomic and you think if it's an
important uh public good then you need
to have limits on liability so it's not
really a it's not a real concern to my
view and not only that but
uh we haven't ever had to use that so
people say it's a subsidy but it's a
it's a limited liability it's never if
it's a subsidy it's never been used
before do we you know part of the
problem with nuclear plants and you know
I'm thinking in particular I remember
Three Mile Island and you know The China
Syndrome had come out a couple weeks
before and like that cemented all of the
the the you know negative mumblings
about nuclear power in the United States
um do we have anything to fear or what
do we have to fear from a Chernobyl from
a Fukushima Three Mile Island ultimately
you know was clearly overwrought the way
that it was treated but I mean you know
is this a categorically different type
of risk than a chemical plant or a gas
and oil plant which you know do explode
from time to time
yeah I would say it's a it's a different
risk I wouldn't say It's a larger one to
be perfectly honest I mean obviously we
had a terrible uh accident with Bhopal
in India where many thousands of people
were killed we have now had two bad
nuclear accidents Fukushima and
Chernobyl
what we know is that the reaction to the
accidents was worse than the accidents
themselves a very common theme and a lot
of domains of modern life but basically
you know you need people need to shelter
in place meaning stay in their home if
there's an accident or there is some
temporary evacuation but people can
return to those places very soon after
you know even we saw three years after
Fukushima they did a study of one of the
of the people's bodies who were in one
of the most radioactive parts of
Fukushima and they had below uh
dangerous limits of radiation from just
eating the food that had been affected
by the radiation so
um you know they cleaned up Fukushima
Fukushima was a low radiation area to
begin with
they they could have left it at Colorado
levels of radiation that's the state I'm
from where people live a very long time
very low rates of cancer
very high radiation so it's the short
version is just Nick that people that
people think that radiation is a super
potent Toxin and it's not it's just the
dose makes the poison and we're
surrounded by radiation all the time and
if an accident happens you just got to
deal with it I mean I pointed out on
Twitter the other day that there was a
shelter in place order
um in Monterey California because the
lithium battery site caught on fire and
it created lots of toxic smoke so
certainly from many many things in
society can create hazards and we manage
it we do it you know we're safer and
healthier than ever
yeah last question from the audience
before we wrap up here from Alan Colvin
what are some thoughts on solar
geoengineering uh Google searches on the
subject of climate change what what are
some thoughts that you might have about
giant atmospheric scrubbers which will
be designed to remove greenhouse gases
from the atmosphere like carbon dioxide
okay I can answer the first one I'm not
sure I can do on the second one yes I
mean there's there's no doubt that we
can cool the Earth by shooting a bunch
of reflective you know solar reflective
particles into the atmosphere
you know like sulfur dioxide
I'm against it and I'm against it
because not because I don't think it can
be done but because I do think it can be
done and I don't think that it could
ever be done democratically how in the
world would you get the consent of all
of the nations of the world to agree to
something like that
I also am just concerned about making
the world colder you got to remember
that more people die of cold than heat
so if you had to choose between global
warming and global cooling you would
choose global warming like I said all
else being equal you wouldn't want to
change the temperature at all but I
don't love the idea of making the Earth
cooler at all it could threaten
agriculture I don't like the
anti-democratic nature of it and in
terms of scrubbers I mean okay here's
what I'll say we have air capture you
can pull carbon dioxide out of the
atmosphere this is very expensive and my
view is just moving from coal to Natural
Gas to nuclear is going to result in the
carbon emissions breaking down over time
um and stabilizing technology that
should be like developed as a kind of
escape hatch if things get too bad like
an emergency lever that you can pull if
you know things do get out of control in
terms of the the rate of warming
well I don't I my concern is I don't
think that that moment could or should
or will arrive in the sense that I don't
again like we said I don't really
believe in the Tipping Point stuff I
just think it's science fiction and also
it wouldn't resolve the problems of of
cooling the the side effects of cooling
the Earth or the Democratic problems I'm
very I'm very concerned about it I
actually am unhappy that Bill Gates and
Harvard are moving forward on it I
thought it was an interesting thought
experiment but it bothers me that
they're still doing it I just it um
yeah it's just it's just undemocratic
and I think humans have made really good
progress in moving away from that kind
of authoritarianism and that kind of you
know environmental dictatorial behaviors
and so yeah I'm I'm just against it um
and it's funny I find it some strange
bedfellows
uh along with me on it but I I don't I
don't like really anything about it
including the catastrophist discourse
that surrounds it
all right we're gonna leave it there
Michael schellenberger best-selling
author of Apocalypse never thanks for
joining reason uh to talk about uh the
war on gas what's gonna you know what
Europe's winter is going to look like
what America's winter spring summer fall
next winter might look like Zach
Weissmuller thanks so much for uh
participating and Manning the tech here
uh and for those of you who are watching
this is going to automatically uh fill
your feed at YouTube in particular in
Facebook it will live on long after all
of us are gone and probably all human
life has been extinguished from uh you
know it'll be there with our cassette
tapes and uh disposable diapers or
something so Michael schellenberger Zach
weismiller thanks so much for uh helping
out good to be with you guys